yeah I don't know I mean like the fish
don't have legs so it's just they check
it out it's a giant they got a booty
face rid of a large about bass this is a
it's a large ass Bass
[Music]
all right who here remembers oh [ __ ]
he's going off one of the most famous
gorillas in the world harambe Coco
absolutely harambe yeah Coco is as well
but harambe is the answer I wish I had a
buzzer I would have won
don't we have buzzers here but Coco's
cocoa is really nice yes she she she had
a kitty cat if I'm gonna get medically
checked by a gorilla
Coco's gentle is Coco dead now yeah
she's been dead yeah but harambe the
focus of this is anybody remember the
story about harambe yeah he was playing
with the kid and then they had to shoot
him up he was playing with a kid he was
doing his thing man that's his nature
yeah yep it was stupid-ass kids he was
prosecuted for being himself this is
true this is true everybody caught up
with the story and stuff like that oh
yeah the stupid ass kid was in his cage
remember what zoo it was where on Earth
did this happen does it say was it it
was in the Cincinnati Zoo yeah back in
2016. yeah incompetence Zoo yeah so it's
a bad name for that obviously uh during
that time I think what also made this a
very very unique kind of social
phenomenon worldwide kind of topic was
it became a cultural meme
harambe meme started popping up
everywhere this is a heavy meme time as
they do you know what I mean and it just
cycled everyone everybody [ __ ] knew
who harambe was uh people are obviously
kind of argumentative about it you know
what I mean like uh who who's in the
right like are you pissed off at the
people that are shooting you know what I
mean no the kid anybody that [ __ ] with
the animal at the zoo that person should
be dead yep I don't give a [ __ ] for
feeding Lions but not just a kid but
also the people that had to shoot
they're just doing their job that's part
of the policy right but the kid
he's acting on his own will of being a
[ __ ] face
[Music]
to his enclosure at the Cincinnati Zoo
and for the safety of the child the
large adult male gorilla is a dangerous
Prospect in situations so the difficult
decision was taken to shoot harambe dead
in that situation I blame cartoons and
it's like I think this video like he's
like kind of playing with it right he's
like it doesn't feel super uh aggressive
it feels much more Curious right fall in
because if he fell in that's different
yeah he was climbing and he fell down he
was climbing he was climbing to get
close to the gorilla and that's why it's
a bad supervisor the dangerous cartoons
who show children hugging gorillas
circadia go into the
enclosure cartoons followed yeah the
kids survive
I'm trying to deflect here but the kid
the kid survived right let's see yes he
went on to uh he went to Harvard so um
there's a slightly new update that has
been uh you know just circling around
lately in regards to harambe and it's
the fact that his Legend now will never
die because after his death they were
able to get his sperm oh wow after his
death after his death interesting did
they did they do gorilla IVF
uh well they haven't yet I think they
did gorilla Pocket [ __ ] oh God
who had that job he's dead no I got
like all right all right he goes it's
like attachment and they're like okay
they make the kids how am I supposed to
get it out you caused this oh [ __ ]
But Mommy I don't want to go to the zoo
anymore like you need to be responsible
for his gene pool continuing they're
like how am I supposed to get it out he
goes you know how it works
watch this cartoon oh man yeah so uh
after his death I I it does not say how
they extracted it but the intention
obviously is to continue his gene pool
and therefore we can have harambe's
Legend harambe too yeah uh continue does
anybody is is everybody like that's
positive news or does anybody feel like
there's any weird
I like it when gorillas do sign language
that's the coolest [ __ ] ever still back
on Coco he's like [ __ ] around there dude
Coco did sideways a whole new species of
gorilla that is bred in captivity and
they can communicate that'll be the
coolest it's like Planet of the Apes
almost you know how like you know how
that turns out tragic and [ __ ] Ah that's
the movies in real life you want to make
a [ __ ] ton of slave Apes that can
communicate
you went there
I just want
immediately you shouldn't have done that
man yeah why'd you go there dude I'm
making it too real I just want I just
want death Apes death so you're gonna
blow their eardrums out too well they're
doing sign language I'm assuming they're
deaf because they can't speak you know
the news people can hear the news people
they hear and they can translate you can
still do sign language even if you're
not deaf yeah it's not a prerequisite
yeah really yeah oh [ __ ] I thought that
the reason why they do sign language is
because they're deaf gorillas what does
that mean [ __ ] oh unless you are
breeding them in captivity to not hear
oh it's kind of like when you get a
goldfish and then you want them with a
big big eyes or the big big butt or
whatever big big butt yeah there's
goldfish with the big big butts that's
weird
he's like give me the ones with the big
butts
[ __ ] goldfish with big boys there's
goldfish with like the brain just
popping out of their parents and [ __ ]
you see those goldfish that's not a butt
yeah there's like weird goldfish you
guys every kind I know you're talking
about I'm just a big butt I can't
imagine I've seen the brain ones yeah
the brain ones that's what I'm talking
about big eyes big brain no there's one
with a big but I'm good there is there
is so what does that mean like the fin
is fat no it's like a fat booty like a
big butt uh goldfish that even works
yeah part of it is the butt if there's
like a there's like a tail it's behind
the tail oh so it's this and then just a
big ass yeah it's a it's a goldfish from
Brazil like they have a nice zip it but
uh it's a Brazilian Arrow isn't a
Brazilian goldfish it's called Brazilian
koi
yeah
everybody's just trying to actually
imagine a [ __ ] goldfish with a GI ant
I think that's why we're all just silent
thinking about this giant asked goldfish
if we could all draw as good as you we
would have it all later here's mine draw
that for us
Sharpie you're gonna draw a goldfish we
have the Sharpie let's see it
oh my God
it is manifesting right now a big butt
goldfish
damn that's so good don't draw it too
good Joe's gonna jack off to it
hey I'm trying to preserve my future
[Laughter]
it's kind of like the Goldfish from it
definitely looks like a penis right now
oh that's a booty yo
goldfish yeah I went SpongeBob's butt
comes out yeah yeah I don't know I mean
like the fish don't have legs so it's
just they check it out it's a giant they
got a booty face I've heard of a large
about bass this is a it's a large ass
Bass
the ball sack that's what I'm saying
damn depends on how you see it I mean or
like a chicken drumstick
yeah I mean we could add legs if you
want hey why not yeah I've already added
an ass
there you go
there you go I'm not going to sign that
one but
you take it and make it hip-hop
so you guys don't think that it's weird
that they took this like gorilla that
was like are you one of those weekends I
mean are you those weak ass animal
activists after he died after he died
that I took his sperm to probably breed
another gorilla in captivity it's it is
sad that's what's sad that's the sad
part about it it doesn't yeah it's not
like they're just gonna like genetically
create harambe and then throw them out
into like what the outside of the
Cincinnati Zoo they're probably gonna
bring him a cat to me oh that's the sad
part where they're like
perpetuating that's my assumption right
like it's kind of the you don't like
science
this guy don't like science I got a lot
of strong opinions man yeah man you know
what I like he's one of those weak ass
animal lovers Flat Earth a weak ass
animal lover
but clearly though they're they're on
the side of the fence that they're
honoring him and they're not like you
know yeah I mean I
I died I'm just kind of like but what's
like to what ends it's a nice thought
it's a nice gesture but also that poor
gorilla like it doesn't know that it's
honoring harambe it's just stuck in a
cage like you guys remember watching
like Blackfish and [ __ ] like that with a
[ __ ] Tilikum [ __ ] whip did you
flip them upside down there Jack them
off grabbing he don't [ __ ] know he's
got 36 children whale and like 16 other
nations that are doing the same slave
[ __ ] and he doesn't know that you know
yeah but do they do they think they want
to know like do they like in the wild do
you think they're like have a
relationship with their children like
they're just like yo Anthony that's my
kid do they want to know you know
um like I don't think that's very
complex that that that come was used for
other purposes yeah maybe he was just
getting a bunch of like weird in
captivity hand jobs and he was down for
that I would have been but the
documentaries and all the stories talk
about how they kind of are in like
suffering and like getting like mentally
crazy and stuff like that because of
like how terrible the conditions are
does it go have you seen the jungle I
guess it's uh I guess it's debatable
wasn't Blackfish kind of a satire
it was a satire of Free Willy